das sind die brandneue kalaschnikow und
eine m 4 mit denen matthew parker
trainiert für den krieg er geht als
waffen ausbilder in die ukraine wir
treffen den 58 jährigen ex soldaten bei
den vorbereitungen in seinem haus in
columbia south carolina der alte kampf
anzug passt noch er hat trainiert alles
muss in einen rucksack passen seine
ausrüstung seine kleidung und das
handtuch dass er von seinen kindern hat
es
ist nicht unser krieg aber wenn sie
durch die ukraine durchmarschieren und
polen estland oder andere länder der
nato angreifen dann ist das die
beistands klausel artikel 5 das ist ein
weltkrieg
wenn wir sie in der ukraine stoppen
stoppen wie einen welt
22 jahre hat parker als unteroffizier
bei den rangers gedient einer elite
einheit die auch in kuwait irak und
bosnien im einsatz war jetzt wird der
teil einer ukrainischen fremdenlegion zu
der sich viele tausend freiwillige aus
aller welt gemeldet haben
wir wissen wie man kämpft so frühen wir
eine brücke oder ein krankenhaus oder
eine schule verteidigen werden wir
erfolgreich sein dadurch und das ist
viel wichtiger verschaffen wir den
ukrainern zeit das ist es was sie
brauchen
parker hilft anderen veteranen bei der
bürokratie dem aufnahmeantrag bei der
ukrainischen armee der genehmigung für
ein fremdes land zu kämpfen die us
regierung rät zwar davon ab aber
verbietet es nicht
brandon sein jüngster sohn selbst
us-soldat wohnt noch hier er sein bruder
und seine zwei schwestern war nicht
überrascht als ihr vater ihnen von
seinem vorhaben erzählt bisher kam dead
immer zurück aus den kriegseinsätzen
darauf hoffen sie weiter meint brandon
stirbt nicht
ein rad
zurück kommt oder nicht er kommt zurück
weil er gegen einen unfähigen feind
kämpft aber er geht dahin um das
richtige zu tun nicht in rust zu töten
sondern menschen zu helfen
parker würde auch lastwagen fahren bei
der medizinischen versorgung helfen
kämpfen so wie diese us veteranen wie am
flughafen warschau ankommen von dort
geht es weiter zur grenze und dann in
ein aufnahme camp der ukrainisch name
die entscheidet wer mit kämpft oder wer
andere aufgaben übernimmt damit eigene
soldaten an die front können
auch waffen und munition kommen vor
allem aus den usa zehntausende
panzerfäuste und flugabwehrraketen der
amerikanische kongress hat gerade
zusätzliche milliarden von dollar
genehmigt aber alexander windmann reicht
das nicht im nationalen sicherheitsrat
hatte er erlebt wie donald trump
präsident selensky waffenlieferungen
verweigerte er fordert dass polen doch
mit 29 kampfjets an die ukraine weiter
geben darf
einige länder haben den tiefen wunsch
aus nationalen sicherheitsinteressen
politischen interessen zu handeln polen
die baltischen staaten aber
sie werden von der nato zurück gehalten
deshalb kann putin die bedingungen
diktieren er muss nur leere drohung über
eine eskalation verbreiten
die amerikanischen javelin raketen seien
zwar großartig meint widmen weil sie
russische kolonnen stoppen aber sie
ließen sich eben nur aus nächster nähe
abgefeuert die nato müsse den
ukrainischen streitkräften waffen geben
mit denen sie der russischen armee die
schwerste niederlage seit afghanistan
beibringen könnten
wenn sie zum beispiel predator und
reaper drohnen vom westen bekehren sowie
die throne von der türkei dann könnten
sie tatsächlich ziele im rückraum
angreifen die luftwaffenbasis mit
russischen kampfflugzeugen die
raketenwerfer vom typ iskander
das wäre ein game changer
sie nutzt einen ausschnitt aus einer
fernsehserie mit eigenem text um in den
informationskrieg einzugreifen das
gelingt uns mit ihrem anführer in
kontakt zu kommen scott free seien 14
computerexperten unter anderem aus den
usa polen der ukraine
sie wollen dass russlands bevölkerung
die wahrheit erfährt
wir wollen aktivisten aus der freien
welt dabei helfen zu kommunizieren
kleine kommunikations brücken zu bauen
zwischen ihnen und den menschen in
russland
so wie einst radio free europe
heutzutage können wir neue technologien
nutzen um die mauer der russischen
zensur zu durchbrechen
auf einer webseite stellen die hacker
sms texte in russisch zur verfügung
anleitungen wie man trotz der zensur an
westliche medien kommt fakten zum
kriegsgeschehen und zur lage in russland
all das können die nutzer dann mit ihren
mobiltelefonen an handynummern
russischer bürger schicken die
aktivisten haben sich millionen von
russischen handynummern effekt und
analysieren auch die reaktionen aus
[Musik]
einige menschen schicken uns garstige
sms weil unsere nachrichten sie wütend
machen
aber es gibt auch viele menschen die
froh sind dass sie solche informationen
bekommt die hungrig sind auf nachrichten
aus aller welt
sogar ex-general hodges 1 kommandeur der
us armee in europa lobt solche aktion
das ist essenziell
genauso wichtig wie die lieferung von
levels und stickern oder wie die
sanktionen das ist eine entscheidende
komponente lisa anstrengen weil es
widerstand im druck aus dem inneren
russlands braucht
auch hauses glaubt dass die nato noch
viel mehr tun müsse als ständig vor
einem dritten weltkrieg zu warnen das
bündnis hierbei manöver in estern sei
stark das gerede von möglicher
eskalation gebe dem kreml nur das signal
dass er in der ukraine freie hand hat
putin werde wohl keinen atomkrieg
riskieren
er könnte eine nuklearwaffe band setzen
ich glaube nicht dass er das tut er ist
nicht in der lage von seinem
schreibtisch aus allein die atomwaffen
einzusetzen
es gibt leute um ihn herum die das auch
nicht erlauben werden weil es russland
letztendlich vernichten will
auch matthew parker will den aggressor
stoppen einige seiner kameraden sind
experten für singles und chaplins je
höher die russischen verluste meinte
desto eher werde sich die russische
bevölkerung gegen putin stellt wir sind
keine sollten wir sind keine kinder egal
was die leute sagen wir sind profis
auch will einen menschen beschützen eine
mutter ein kind eine familie ein dorf
ich will jemanden verteidigen gegen
einen schurken
ein 58 jähriger wetteraner bereit in den
krieg zu ziehen sein leben zu riskieren
für die menschen in der ukraine
[Musik]